gérard dine à leur tour de france 1975
je n'apprécie pas parce que c'est un
prétentieux de nombreux supporters
français avait une dent après le coureur
belge eddy merckx
[Musique]
mais pourquoi tant de haine
retour en 1969
le jeune belge remporte le tour de
france pour la première fois il a tout
juste 24 ans et il impressionne le
public et les journalistes
et voici eddy merckx la nouvelle idole
du sport cycliste en belgique et même en
france car mr tu es devenu presque aussi
populaire que poulidor dans notre pays
un an plus tard en 1970 merckx dévore
tous ses adversaires sur le tour et ça
commence légèrement à énerver
d'autant que le sportif garde un rapport
très distant avec les médias jamais un
homme a dominé ce sport comme vous le
dominer n'oubliez pas la langue de
france est un peu les gens le principe
du sport série américaine je crois
et en 1970 c'est bien lui le meilleur
il gagne le tour et son soigneur répond
aux questions du journaliste
je voudrais répondre à une remarque que
fait souvent le public qui dit eddy
merckx une souris pas ils ne rient pas
hammerfall n'est pas payée pour y aller
il est payé pour pédaler payer pour
pédaler et ça marche
il gagne le tour 71 le tour 72 le tour
de france c'est fini
eddy merckx l'emporter pour la quatrième
fois consécutive
il ne participe pas au tour de france
mais en 1974 il en revient au plus grand
regret de ses adversaires car courir en
face de celui que l'on appelle désormais
le cannibale a de quoi démotiver
est ce qu'un garçon comme vous à a peur
un peu de dignité de la personnalité
d'eddy merckx bien oui il ya toujours un
complexe eddy merckx avec ce qu'il a
fait jusqu'à présent
on n'ose pas trop l'attaqué 1974 c'est
encore le belge qui gagne le tour alors
en 1975 trop c'est trop pour certains
supporters
gagnent trop qu'il est trop fort et même
trop belge avec talon par laquelle une
partie du public j'ai une partie qui a
l'air de vous en vouloir d'être fort non
oui je crois que c'est toujours comme ça
lorsqu'on réussit pas toujours là
toujours envié par quelqu'un un
supporter du tour vais jusqu'à devenir
violent un bras jaillissant de la haie
humaine se détend et prat maire de
sceaux fois je souffle coupé
il terminera la course complètement
asphyxiés
[Applaudissements]
les dîners axe finira deuxième du tour
de france 1975 6e en 1977
aucun autre coureur cycliste n'a son
palmarès le belge est devenu une légende
au de l'adn
[Musique]